pour en débattre nous sur nous avec un
jean de maillard ancien magistrat
spécialiste des affaires économiques et
financières
yves d'amécourt conseiller régional
nouvelle aquitaine ex les républicains
bonsoir a tous des deux merci d'être en
direction rt france
jean de maillard vous êtes donc anciens
un magistrat donc va être bien passé
pour par ces parler de ces sujets
nicolas sarkozy qui est devenu le
premier président être condamné à de la
prison ferme trois ans en prison dont un
ferme comment vous qu'elle est férié
cette peine écoutez elle a l'apparence
de la sévérité c'est certain mais il
faut pas non plus le citron p si les
juges aujourd'hui peuvent être le sévère
dans la symbolique des peines c'est
aussi parce qu'ils savent que ces peines
ne seront pas appliquées parce que en
dessous de 2 ans d'emprisonnement
les peines ne sont pas exécutées
monsieur cahuzac par exemple n'a fait
aucun jour de prison donc c'est une
sorte d'oxygène qui est donné aux
tribunaux de pouvoir prononcer des
peines purement symbolique qui vont
faire croire aux citoyens qu'il y à une
égalité des justiciables devant la
justice mais c'est pas tout à fait le
cas symbolique uniquement ça va
travailler aussi yves d'amécourt comment
réagit l'ancien soutien de nicolas
sarkozy et de françois fillon
non c'est pas symbolique comme ça c'est
nous dira comment le juge d'application
des peines va commuer sa peine
après ça pour le président de république
mais c'est surtout une justice qu'on ne
comprend pas en fait je pense que dans
un pays dans une démocratie il faut que
les décisions qui sont prises soient
comprises aujourd'hui on comprend plus
grand chose dans les décisions qui sont
prises et cette décision de justice on
l'a on la comprend pas notamment dans
notre pays on avait un certain nombre de
principes par exemple le doute profite à
l'accusé et on a l'impression que dans
ce procès le dot a profité à
l'accusation
ensuite on avait un autre principe qui
était qu'il fallait des preuves
tangibles pour pouvoir accuser et là on
a l'impression que c'est plus tôt
à d'ailleurs dans les bons même que le
parquet national financier à utiliser
dans ses réquisitions il parle de 10
nous pensons nous croyons nous imaginons
voilà on est dans la présomption d'une
attention à agir face est très curieux
comme façon de juger
alors c'est vrai qu'elle est politique
notamment évidemment à droite sont très
remontés par cette décision de schiste
on propose d'écouter la réaction de
valérie boyer sénatrice les républicains
des bouches du rhône
il y aura un avant et un après cette
affaire sarkozy que je lis à la sphère
fillon puisque je rappelle que sans le
pnf emmanuel macron ne serait pas
président de la république puisque le
débat présidentiel a été volé aux
français à la place on a eu le procès de
françois fillon
donc on voit bien que cette intervention
d'une sévérité inédite a perturbé la vie
politique française
cette affaire est susceptible de
remettre en cause les fondements de
l'état de droit
jean maillard est ce que vous comprenez
tout de même la colère les questions
demande valérie boyer aujourd'hui c'est
d'une certaine manière toute la droite
qui s'interroge c'est vrai que le pnf
condamne souvent les personnes on va
dire à droite françois fillon en sait
quelque chose beaucoup moins à gauche en
tout cas c'est l'accusation qui revient
très régulièrement tout compris par
certaines personnes de gauche quel est
votre avis sur cette question
oui mais je comprends très bien mais je
crois que dit le dicton qui dit c'est
pas parce qu'on a manqué une fois qu'on
est toujours eu menteur le le parquet
national financiers dans la sphère
fillon a manifestement été
instrumentalisée je crois que quiconque
quelle bonne foi est obligé de le
reconnaître
il ya eu une enquête hitler du parquet
national financiers une ouverture est
clair de dune information judiciaire ce
qui ne se fait jamais dans les affaires
économiques et financières
le parquet a saisi les juges
d'instruction il a choisi ses juges
d'instruction et le monsieur sarkozy
avait été mis par monsieur fillon à
l'époque avait été mis en examen d'une
façon il clair dans des délais donc dans
laquelle la justice ne fonctionne jamais
donc de ce point de vue là je l'entends
crée bien les critiques qui est faite au
fonctionnement judiciaire
en revanche dans la sphère sarkozy je ne
crois pas que ce soit la même chose et
je pense donc il faut pas tout mélanger
monsieur sarkozy je ne me prononcerai
pas sur le fond du dossier mais on peut
dire comme le fait mon interlocuteur que
l'on condamne sans preuve mais j'y vais
on parle aussi sans savoir et on parle
sans preuve on peut toujours accusé les
juges de d'intention malveillante
d'arrière-pensées mais on ne démontre
pas notre langue donc dans ce domaine là
il faut pas je crois que c'est on peut
dire un petit peu n'importe quoi mais il
faut il faut essayer de rester sur des
choses concrètes
monsieur sarkozy a eu toutes les
possibilités d'exercer les droits de la
défense il était jusqu'en cour de
cassation un il y va régulièrement il
fera appel
peut-être sera-t-il relaxé en appel
peut-être sera-t-il condamné il ira
encore en cour de cassation et je
reviens quand même sur ce que je disais
tout à l'heure il n'y va jamais en
prison en tout état de cause parce que
notre code de procédure pénale
à la limite nous permet pas de mettre
monsieur sarkozy en prison même s'il est
condamné à deux ans de prison ferme
la réalité des choses autre réaction
aujourd'hui qu'on rocher salle de marine
le pen propose de l'écouter il y a
beaucoup de choses qui me gêne dans
cette affaire la première c'est que je
considère que la conversation entre un
avocat et son client est sacrée je pense
qu'il en va de la bonne administration
de la justice mais aussi de la
démocratie cette affaire est vicié dès
le départ le dossier a été pris en main
par le parquet national financier qui a
été créée par les politiques et
notamment madame taubira
il est devenu le parquet de l'opposition
je pense qu'il ya un problème
d'impartialité du pfl ap élève devenu le
parti de l'opposition vous êtes d'accord
avec cet intitulé
ils veulent des cours oui c'est
d'ailleurs assez incroyable que dans le
juge nous reproche au président sarkozy
de ne pas avoir été le garant de
l'indépendance de la justice
alors que le parquet national financier
lui ai clairement aux ordres du pouvoir
d'ailleurs dans un article de 2016 jean
de maillard se plaignaient de cette
évolution de la justice avec un pouvoir
de plus en plus important du parquet qui
finalement enlevé au juge d'instruction
du pouvoir et entraîné la justice dans
dans un dans un scénario que l'on est en
train de vivre aujourd'hui en fait je
remercie le sud avec pour qui la bonne
lecture c'est vrai je j'ai toujours été
personnellement hostile au parquet
national financier je le reste parce que
je pense que lille
conjuguent tous les défauts de notre
système de procédure pénale et notre
organisation judiciaire
mais ce sont je suis désolé de le dire
ce sont les politiques qui l'ont voulu
les les juges me et bien ils sont en ce
qui concerne les magistrats du parquet
sont directement aux ordres de la
chancellerie
on l'a vu d'ailleurs lorsque madame
blais qui était l'ancien procureur du
parquet national financier a été obligé
de reconnaître devant la représentation
nationale que l avait le subit de fortes
pressions et ces pressions d'exister ces
pressions peuvent exister mais en
l'occurrence ce n'est pas le parquet
national financier qui est concerné par
la sphère sarkozy l' affaire sarkozy
elle a été suivi un cursus judiciaire
habituel et les monsieur sarkozy lui
toutes les possibilités de me faire
valoir sa défense et il aurait encore
tout la possibilité toutes les
possibilités d'olten
il va d'amécourt nicolas sarkozy parce
que jean de maillard parlé d' une peine
symbolique il n'empêche pas nicolas
sarkozy se défend de vouloir agir en
quoique on n'est jamais à l'abri de rien
en politique ça aura du lourd de
conséquences je pense que ce n'est
jamais mort d d'ailleurs c'est alain
juppé qui avait je crois a gagné le prix
d'humour politique en disant qu'il
valait mieux avoir
il disait on n'est jamais mort en
politique la preuve je suis toujours là
voilà
et on sait qu'il était passé lui aussi
par un certain nombre de situations
complexes notamment dans la sphère des
des emplois fictifs de la ville de paris
donc voilà la justice elle passe et puis
une fois qu'elle est passée normalement
on regagne son statut donc il faut et
puis et puis les gens jugent par eux
mêmes ce qui est bien et ce qui l'est ce
qui est moins bien de de la façon dont
on est juge
et de la justesse de la justice ce qui
est curieux dans cette affaire c'est que
les méthodes qui ont été utilisés sont
un petit peu curieuse d'ailleurs le juge
renaud van ryn date lui même comme il
l'avait fait d'ailleurs pour la faire
fillon sur la sphère sarkozy a dit qu'il
était un petit peu étonné de la façon
dont on avait lancé des filets pour
écouter des conversations recueillir des
informations
en fait la méthode qui est utilisée est
quand même très ressemble quand même
très fort au roman de george orwell et
donc je pense que chacun de nous si on
était écoutée en permanence sur nos
conversations téléphoniques
et si après ça on avait des petites
mains qui essayaient de mettre en
relation les conversations d1 avec les
conversations des autres de monter
d'échafauder des plans sur la comète
d'essayer de trouver des des complots
c'est un peu c'est un peu comme si le
parquet national financier s'était amusé
à construire des thèses complotistes sur
les relations de nicolas sarkozy du
magistrat gilbert et de l'avocat est
recevable
nico maillard d'avoir accepté ce face à
face on directe ur rt france merci à
vous